they'll be taking on that man right
there frankie montos making his
24th start of the season
and frankie coming off a decent outing
against the chicago white sox went five
innings
surrendered three runs did strike out
six but tied a season high three walks
so for frankie who's had that split
finger
dancing
see if he can get ahead of guys and
start to wipe them out maybe avoid some
of those extended bats we see frankie
get into at times
play baseball
first pitch of the game
hit toward tony kemp who takes a couple
steps to his left scoops it up
and that is out number one so one pitch
one out for frankie montas
and he got him swinging 99 again
hit high in the air
right field brown is there so that's a
good first inning for frankie montas
three up three down with a strikeout a's
come to bat when we come back
taking the map for the giants this
afternoon in oakland is logan webb he's
on the middle of a hot streak see the
numbers there
strikeouts uh
over strikeout and inning
but really been rolling the last five
starts 3-0 with a 1-7-2 era
three pitches
one down
in the bottom of the first
and he chases this one and hits it up
the middle but they're behind the bag at
first is la stella and on one pitch
marte is retired
[Applause]
and he goes the other way olson does and
he's got a base hit see if ruff can hold
olson
olsen will head into second base and
they got him
2 42 against
lefties 3-2 pitch swinging a ground ball
to the right side there's bryant at
second base
the third baseman playing second base
throws out lowry
mound was the other in the other
direction here's a sweat i'm gonna miss
strikeout number two
[Applause]
here's a slider he struck him out
swinging
well by the sound of the crowd somebody
made a nice play probably a bare hand
snag oh yeah you know what generally we
would say you know what you need to
bring glove but the fact that he's
keeping score well he's okay
swing at a miss got him away
darting fastball in 98 with movement
olson's got it he'll flip to frankie
montage wade is retiring
center field marte comes in and now he
waits and he grabs it so one toss gets
out of the jam
lots of fun here's brown who won the
first pitch lifts it to left ruff
going back back pedaling and he makes
the catch right at the top of his glove
[Applause]
swing
i'm gonna miss a three-pitch strikeout
number four bringing kemp to the plate
cannon goes around and strikes out for
the second time five
for webb outfit a bit the other way on
crawford as the hands away from the body
and the 2-2
swing at a miss got him on a split
disappear to the dirt nice job keeping
it nearby by gomes
way in the dirt posey's going to get
caught off
and that's another mistake by the giants
but that's all about yon gomes doing
work behind the dish
strike three called outside corner brian
can't believe it slams his bat down he
thought it was outside
so now harrison steps up he struck out
in the second
bounce slowly la stella is going to have
to get rid of it he does and that's
going to end the inning
swung on a miss on a split or perfect
pitch dickerson
instead he got a strikeout he'll take it
rough tardy
run or go on the 3-2 pitch by frankie
here it is and it's swung on a high fly
ball playable short right center it four
of these out there martay emphatically
is calling the rest of the guys scatter
and marty makes the catch
two-two pitch sliders struck him out
swinging
there's a swing and a drive into
right center in and to his right comes
weight and he makes the catch yes did
not get any kind of a read on that ball
sharply on the ground to crawford from
the hole
to brandon belt and that'll end the
inning
[Applause]
there's a line drive but right into the
glove of tony kemp
and he got him swinging
belt swung right over top second time he
has struck out seven strikeouts
center field marte going back he's going
to get there stops and he makes the
catch
and that one is fair right down the
third base line bangs off the side wall
kemp's gonna have a double to lead off
the sixth
tony kemp continues to get on base and
here's kenna over two with two k's
that's gonna be a base hit to right
field here comes camp picked up by wade
the throw is way off line goes to the
back stop and kenna goes to second and
the a's lead one nothing
here's marte
rounded toward short crawford has a kick
away
and cannon is going to stop at third
and that's a very sure-handed brandon
crawford take a look
right there it does it ends up catching
that right foot so i feel like it's
going to stay here oh you follow him out
wow chad's over
tapped right back to where it came from
and that'll end the inning the damage is
a run
[Applause]
crawford a little pop-up reached for it
and chapman
is gonna grab it
and he got him splitter well off the
plate brian strikes out for the second
time
and he got it
chased a splitter and looked bad doing
it so here is solano now to pinch it for
wade
and solano hits a high drive to left
it is out of here
they've done it again the giants take
the lead on a pinch-hit-home run
seen this movie before donovan salado
does it and the giants
you can't defend a walk it happened last
night can't defend the walk next guy
hits the homer look at that dugout team
picture and this was a no doubter team
picture and the a's have second and
third and two outs so olson steps in
shot to third flores has it on a tough
hop the throw the first in time for the
out big pitch here
and he got him with a slider so flores
chased it so now josh harrison will try
to get a board
that one is bounce fair
just past flores down the third base
line it's a long run for rough to get to
it he finally picks it up harrison's
going to stop at second with a one-out
double two out two to one san francisco
tiger one at second so here's pinder
here's the pitch
he struck him out a fastball on the
outside corner and the giants hang on to
win it and they take this series
you